this is a hidden front line between
russia and ukraine a front line of cyber
espionage and cyber war
some of the blurred faces are russians
who ukraine and its western backers are
trying to trace for allegedly committing
war crimes russian cryptocurrency
transactions are also being monitored
we're analyzing the movement of russian
digital assets she says the black
circles are the crypto wallets of those
registered on the blockchain the yellow
circles are the crypto exchanges
we know cryptocurrency helps finance the
killing of our soldiers and civilians
she says
since the beginning of the year there
have been 47 major anti-ukraine cyber
campaigns 44 of them happened since the
invasion i'm talking about campaigns i
mean multiple attacks against
governmental bodies the private sector
internet providers and telecommunication
companies
experts say russia's cyber warfare aims
at undermining public confidence in
ukraine's leadership it also targets
sectors involved in the movement of
military personnel equipment money and
people
they say the attacks began accelerating
after moscow's annexation of crimea in
2014 but have grown more aggressive in
recent months the attacks include a
february the 10th attempted hack of at
least 21 companies involved in the
production and distribution of liquefied
natural gas then the day before the
invasion february the 23rd there was a
so-called wiper attack
targeting various ukrainian government
ministries
we're calling him alexei to hide his
identity he's one of what's estimated to
be thousands of ukrainians working for
the government and private sector or as
volunteers in the so-called cyber army a
loose network of hackers that have
appeared since the start of the war
alexey is involved in both defensive and
offensive operations he claims to have
helped in an attack on one of russia's
biggest banks
the ceba bank website was hacked so
badly that even the company shares
crashed other specialists concentrate on
crucial russian infrastructure they find
access to russian video surveillance
communication and navigation systems an
attack on the russian aviation industry
was so strong that the switch to paper
documentation they wiped out
approximately 70 terabytes of
information ukraine gets millions of
dollars worth of cyber security
assistance from western intelligence
agencies private contractors and
international companies including
microsoft and cisco
a widely feared russian cyber attack on
ukraine with so-called spillover effects
and global consequences hasn't happened
poor russian cyber offense good
ukrainian defense some experts say
but the war in ukraine has become an
experiment in cyber warfare on an
unprecedented scale charles stratford al
jazeera kiev